So far we've been looking at cameras but we've been actually looking at
the details of the optics, that is how light enters through the optics.
And of course at the back,
at the focal lens of the camera where the image is formed.
Now let's talk about how to save the image.
In this kind of camera, a film camera, a film is placed here and
it's the chemical process of the film that takes the light and preserves it.
By changing the chemistry on the film and that is stored to create prints.
And this lesson will talk about the composition of the film itself.
But also, since we are actually moving to the world of digital photography we'll
talk about the composition.
And how something like a CCD, a charge couple device, is used to save
information in an electronic form or electrical energy form, from light.
We'll also discuss concepts of bare filtering,
that allow us to talk about different colors.
And also a CMOS sensor, which is the one that's widely in use for
all the cameras that we actually currently use these days.